INTERVIEW.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS THE
PRESIDENT OF FRANCE, EMMANUEL
MACRON IN AN EXCLUSIVE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE.
YOU GAVE A VERY FORCEFUL SPEECH
AT THE UNITED NATIONS.
YOU SAID THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
MAKING A NEW MISTAKE FOLLOWING
HIS ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE'S GOING
TO MOBILIZE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF RUSSIAN TROOPS.
HAD YOU SAID HE HAS MADE RUSSIA
MORE AND MORE ISOLATED BECAUSE
OF A WAR YOU SAID WAS ILLEGAL
AND ILLEGITIMATE.
YOU ARE PERHAPS THE WESTERN
LEADER WHO HAS HAD MORE TIME
TALKING WITH PUTIN ONE-ON-ONE
THAN ANY OTHER.
WHY DO YOU THINK HE'S DOING
THIS?
AND CAN HE BE TALKED OUT OF IT?
>> LOOK.
I -- IT'S HARD TO ME TO GIVE AN
EXPLANATION.
I THINK THIS IS NOT THE MOST
RATIONAL DECISION FOR SURE.
WHEN DECIDES TO LAUNCH A WAR
21st OF FEBRUARY, I THINK HE
MADE THE FIRST MISTAKE, A HUGE
ONE.
AND DECIDED TO SHOW THE
SITUATION AND YET TO BE THE NEW
IMPERIAL COUNTRY AND TO LAUNCH A
COLD WAR.
DURING THE PAST FEW MONTHS, I
HAVE TO SAY THAT ALL OF US WERE
VERY IMPRESSED BY THE RATION OF
THE RESISTANCE OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
WE HUGGED THEM FROM A MILITARY
POINT OF VIEW, BUT THEY DID
RESIST.
AND I THINK THEY DID MUCH BETTER
THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT A
FEW MONTHS AGO.
NOW, I THINK AFTER THE
COUNTEROFFENSES, VLADIMIR PUTIN
IS MUCH MORE UNDER PRESSURE.
AND AFTER ESPECIALLY SOME CLEAR
STATEMENTS MADE BY A LOT OF
LEADERS, NOT JUST WESTERN
LEADERS.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, VLADIMIR PUTIN
CONVEYS A MESSAGE I WAS
ADDRESSED BY UNITED NATIONS.
THEY TRIGGERED THE SITUATION AND
I JUST REACTED.
NOW, IT'S CLEAR FOR EVERYBODY
THAT THE LEADER WHO DECIDED TO
GO TO WAR, THE LEADER WHO WILL
DECIDED TO ESCALATE, IS
PRESIDENT PUTIN.
AND I HAVE NO RATIONAL
INFORMATION.
I THINK THIS IS A SERIES OF
RESENTMENT.
IS THIS A STRATEGY OF IT, AND
THIS IS A POST FEBRUARY 19th
CONSEQUENCE.
HE'S ISOLATED.
>> YOU THINK HE'S ISOLATED.
>> I THINK SO.
I THINK SO.
>> DO YOU THINK THE COUNTLESS
HOURS YOU'VE SPENT REACHING OUT
TO HIM, ATTEMPTING DIPLOMACY, DO
YOU THINK THAT HAS BEEN HELPFUL
OR WILL BE HELPFUL?
>> WE WILL KNOW THAT AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
I'M SURE, YEARS AND YEARS WE
CHANCELLOR MERKEL, WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME TO SPEAK WITH
PRESIDENT BORIS YELTSIN AND WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
IN TRYING TO IMPLEMENT THE MINSK
AGREEMENT SIGNED WAS THE BEST
WAY TO AVOID ESCALATION.
I THINK WHAT WE GOT IN 2019 WAS
VERY POSITIVE FOR UKRAINE.
AND WAS DEFINITELY A PROGRESS
FOR THIS.
BUT AS I TOLD YOU,
POST-COVID-19, THERE WAS A
SITUATION, AND HE DECIDED TO
BREAK THE SITUATION AND GO TO
THE WAR.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THE
SUSPICIONS WE HAD.
SECOND, I THINK IN HIS OWN
LOGIC, I'M NOT SAYING THIS IS AN
EXPLANATION OR I DON'T GIVE AN
EXCUSE, BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT THERE IS A
LOT OF RESENTMENT ON THE RUSSIAN
SIDE.
YOU HAVE A FEELING THAT POST
1990, WE DIDN'T RESPECT HIM
TOTALLY.
I THINK IT'S A REASON.
TO DO WHAT HE DID.
>> BUT IT'S HIS MIND-SET?
>> IT'S HIS MIND-SET, IT'S
ACTUALLY TO BE MORE RESPECTFUL
AND FIND A WAY WHEN YOU HAVE
THIS DECISION.
I THINK, FOR INSTANCE, THANKS TO
THIS DIALOGUE, WING WERED TO
ORGANIZE THIS MISSION WITH
NATIONAL DIPLOMACY TO GO TO
ZAPORIZHZHIA AND HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT MISSION AND WE ARE,
I HOPE, FINALIZING A VERY
IMPORTANT AGREEMENT TO PROTECT
THIS NUCLEAR POWER PLANT.
AND GO TO DDEMILITARIZATION, BU
AT LEAST MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
MORE WEAPONS IN THIS AREA.
I WANT TO INSIST ON THAT.
WE HAVE TO AVOID THE ABUSES OF
WAR.
WE HAVE TO HELP UKRAINE COULD BE
FREE AND GET THE FULL CONTROL OF
ITS TERRITORY.
BUT AT THE POINT OF TIME --
>> DOES THAT INCLUDE CRIMEA.
>> IT WOULD BE UKRAINE TO DECIDE
IT.
THE UKRAINIANS AND THE RUSSIANS
WOULD HAVE TO GO AT THE TABLE TO
NEGOTIATE.
SO IT WOULD BE THE END OF THIS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID AT THE
U.N. THAT RUSSIA ISN'T JUST
ATTACKING UKRAINE, RUSSIA IS
ATTACKING THE UNITED NATIONS
CHARTER.
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE YOU HAVE HERE IN THE
UNITED NATIONS SECURITY COUNCIL
A COUNTRY, RUSSIA, THAT HAS
COMMITTED HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES.
AND POTENTIAL WAR CRIMES.
INVADED A SOVEREIGN NATION AND
ON AND ON.
HAS RUSSIA PROVE THAN THE U.N.
DOES NOT WORTH THE BUILDING IT'S
IN?
BECAUSE THE U.N. CAN'T STOP IT?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO BECAUSE
NOBODY PROPOSED AN ALTERNATIVE
ORDER OR A MORE EFFICIENT ONE.
>> YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
ARE SKEPTICAL OF U.N. WHEN YOU
HAVE RUSSIA ON THE SECURITY
COUNCIL?
>> WELL, SURE.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE AFRICAN
CONTINENT AND SOME EMERGENT
COUNTRIES THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES TO MAKE
THIS INTERNATIONAL CERTAINLY.
BUT WE HAVE TO PRESERVE OUR
VENUES AND THE CHARTER.
EVERYBODY IS AT STAKE.
WE ARE SPEAKING ABOUT RESPECT OF
SOVEREIGNTY.
AND IT'S EXACTLY WHY WE BUILD
THIS CHARTER, POST WORLD WAR II
AND AFTER THE COLONIZATION AREA.
I THINK DEFENDING THIS PRINCIPLE
IS NOT JUST DEFENDING UKRAINE.
IT'S DEFENDING ALL OF THE
COUNTRIES AND POSSIBILITY OF
PEACE IN THE WORLD.
DURING THE PAST FEW MONTHS YOU
HAVE THE NATIONALITY AND THE
WEST VERSUS THE REST.
THIS IS A BIG DANGER.
>> YOU HAVE SAID THAT CHINA AND
INDIA AND SOME OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE SIDING WITH THIS RUSSIAN
IMPERIALISM THROUGH THEIR
COMPLICITY, BY NOT STANDING
AGAINST RUSSIA'S AGGRESSION OF
UKRAINE.
ARE YOU SEEING ANY INDICATION
THAT CHINA, INDIA, SOME OF THESE
COUNTRIES IN THE AFRICAN WORLD
ARE SEEING YOUR ARGUMENT,
HEARING PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ARGUMENT THAT THE WORLD HAS TO
ALIGN WITH DEMOCRACY AND
REPUBLICS AND AGAINST
AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNMENTS.
IS THERE ANY HOPE?
>> I DO BELIEVE THERE IS HOPE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE VERY
RESPECTFUL.
I THINK WE HAVE TO AVOID
LECTURING PEOPLE AND SAYING WE
ARE ON THE GOOD SIDE OF THE
STORY.
IF WE HAVE A LOT OF
UNDERSTANDING, AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY DO BELIEVE
IN AND WHAT THEIR FEELINGS, WE
CAN'T CONDEMN THEM.
THESE GUYS ARE DIFFERENT FROM
IT.
LET'S ALL TOGETHER BEING
RESPECTFUL WE CAN WORK --
BECAUSE WHAT IS AT STAKE IS
GLOBAL ORDER.
PEACE, CLIMATE CHANGE, FOOD
SECURITY.
ALL OF THESE THINGS CAN BE FIXED
IF WE HAVE COOPERATION BETWEEN
THE U.S., EUROPE, CHINA, INDIA,
ASIA PACIFIC.
AFRICA.
>> SO YOUR ALLY, ALLY GERMANY
HAS BEEN CRITICIZED.
THAT IS THIS ENOUGH, DO THEY
NEED TO DO MORE?
>> I MEAN, IT'S VERY UNFAIR TO
BLAME SOMEBODY.
BECAUSE THIS WAR, NOBODY
PREDICTED A FEW MONTHS AGO.
AND THE WAY TO FUNCTION IS THAT
THEY LISTEN TOGETHER.
ON THE FACT THAT TRADE,
COOPERATIONS, INTEGRATIONS OF
VALUE CHAINS IS PROBABLY THE
BEST FOR ANY COUNTRY.
I MEAN, THE RATIONAL OF THE PAST
DECADE.
IT'S TRUE, WHAT EUROPE IS APT TO
ADAPT TO IS THAT WE WERE BASED
ON A MODEL.
AND GERMANY MORE THAN FRANCE
BECAUSE WE ARE NUCLEAR POWER.
BUT WE ARE IN PERFECT
SOLIDARITY.
WE HAVE TO SHIFT FROM THE MODEL
WHERE WE THOUGHT COOPERATING
WITH EVERYBODY IS THE BEST WAY
TO PRESERVE WAR.
AND TO WHERE YOU HAVE TO BUILD
MORE INDEPENDENCE IN SOME WAY.
SO, THIS IS WHY I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER OF SOVEREIGNTY.
IN TECHNOLOGY, SECURITY, FOR
DIGITAL-BASED TECHNOLOGY,